in regelmäßigen abständen im
wochenrhythmus oder zumindest zwei
wochen rhythmus diskutieren wir darüber
ob wir noch härtere chor ohne regeln
brauchen ist ihr lockdown einfach zu
lasch gewesen
ja also schon bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 14
oktober haben wir ja sehr intensiv um
die frage gerungen wie viele maßnahmen
müssen jetzt sein
und seitdem sehen wir eben die zahlen
gehen nicht richtig runter sondern wir
haben ein plateau erreichen das ist
nicht nichts sondern da haben wir schon
wirklich ja viele einschränkende
maßnahmen auch gemeinsam umsetzen müssen
aber dafür dass wir wieder unter 50
kommen muss einfach noch mehr passieren
da war ganz klar das war ja das ziel sie
wollten bin november also innerhalb
dieser vier wochen runterkommen auf die
50 wieder davon sind sie weit entfernt
gestartet sind sie mit ungefähr 126
incidents wert jetzt sind wir bei über
140 heute aktuell wieder incidents wert
bundesweit das heißt da ist das sogar
gestiegen wenn man sich das anguckt ziel
ja komplett verfehlt
naja erstmal ist es ja nicht komplett
verfehlt wenn man von einem
exponentiellen wachstum auf dem plateau
kommt aber mir war auch immer wichtig zu
sagen
lange ein plateau halten ergibt noch gar
keinen sinn weil das können wir nur
durch dauer beschränkungen die am ende
sehr teuer sind und sicherlich auch
wieder von der bevölkerung und schon gar
nicht von der davon betroffenen
wirtschaften auch dauerhaft akzeptiert
werden das heißt jetzt muss man sagen
wir müssen weiter darüber diskutieren
was wir noch tun können
und da ist ja ein thema zum beispiel die
ganze zeit schon das thema schule dass
wir sehen dass die ansteckungsfähigkeit
bei den älteren schülern ab der also
wahrscheinlich so naja also dass es gibt
zwei schritte man kann einmal so ein
wechsel unterricht machen oder man kann
wirklich komplett distanz unterricht
machen das heißt die schüler gehen nach
hause und kriege quasi online
homeschooling und was befürworten sie
ich bin dafür dass man in den hotspots
die also wirklich jetzt weit weit
oberhalb des durchschnitts kann sollte
glücklich distanzen unterricht macht bei
den älteren